The Android Wear platform
is flexible enough
to allow your app to display
information to the user
whenever it's useful.
Now, this includes sharing
fitness information, travel
updates, or to-do
lists for as long
as the user might need them.
However, doing this
in the usual fashion
means keeping the screen
on full brightness
and providing constant updates.
This can have a big
impact on battery life.
But with Always-On, your app
can present useful information
while the watch is
in ambient mode,
keeping your user informed while
also saving precious power.
Hi, I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is a quick introduction
to keeping your Android Wear
app always on.
Android Wear operates
in two primary states--
interactive and ambient.
When in interactive
mode, the watch
can display full color
with fluid animation
and can respond to
user interactivity.
This is typically when the user
is giving focused attention
to their watch.
Ambient mode is
a low power state
that uses a limited
color palette is
updated less frequently.
This is the typical
state for the watch
while the user goes
about their day.
Always-On simply allows your
app to stay in the foreground
while the watch is
in ambient mode.
Think of it like this.
Your user is in the
grocery store and loads
your app to get
their shopping list.
They see they need milk and
head to the dairy aisle.
After a few moments, the
watch goes into ambient mode.
Previously, your app
would have closed
and the watch face would
take the foreground.
However, now that you've
implemented Always-On,
you get to continue displaying
relevant information
to the user.
It's the best of both worlds.
The user gets to
continue using your app,
while also maintaining
battery life.
Before we dive into
the API specifics,
let's look at a few quick
design considerations.
The update frequency
you choose can
be the difference between
a great experience
and losing any power saving
value Always-On has to offer.
Although you can choose any
frequency between, say, 10
in 60 seconds,
the default is 60.
And you should only change it if
your app needs it to be useful.
For example, a shopping
app is fine at the default,
whereas most fitness apps will
want to update more frequently.
Another important battery
life consideration
is how many pixels you light
up and what color you use.
More pixels means more power.
You should use grayscale
colors and keep around
95% of the screen black.
This is especially
important to prevent
burn-in for OLED screens,
but also signals to the user
that they're actually
in ambient mode
and they'll need to
wake up the watch
before they can
interact with it.
It's also important
to avoid presenting
any buttons or other
interactive elements
when the watch is
in ambient mode.
Touching the screen will
actually bring the user back
to interactive mode.
It won't trigger the button.
One last thing.
Consider the user's privacy
when displaying data
in ambient mode.
For example, keeping a
messaging app on the screen
could be convenient
for a user who
is in an ongoing conversation.
But displaying personal
messages on the screen
for an extended period of
time might bother some users.
Consider removing
potentially private data
after a short period of
being in ambient mode,
or refrain from showing
sensitive data in ambient mode
at all.
Adding Always-On to
your app is simply
a task of implementing
a different view mode.
Here are the four primary things
you've got to do to set up.
You currently need API level 22
or higher, or level 20 and up
if you plan to support
backwards compatibility.
Make sure you have these
dependencies in your gradle
build file.
Add the wearable shared library
in the wearable app manifest.
And add the WAKE LOCK permission
to the handheld and wearable
app manifests.
That's it.
Now you're ready
to start coding.
You'll want to create
the Always-On activity.
It should extend
wearable activity.
In the onCreate method
of this activity,
call setAmbientEnabled.
When the watch switches
to ambient mode,
the system calls the
onEnterAmbient method.
Override this method to update
your UI to a more basic view.
Don't move anything around.
You'll want to keep
the same layout.
But you'll transform into
a limited color palette,
stop using anti-aliasing, and
remove interactive controls
such as buttons and so on.
When the user taps the screen
or brings up their wrist,
the activity switches from
ambient to interactive mode,
and the system calls the
onExitAmbient method.
Here you can switch back to your
full color interactive layout.
While the activity
is in ambient mode,
the system will periodically
call onUpdateAmbient.
The default is
once every minute,
though you can create an
alarm manager to update
the screen more frequently.
You might do this for
a running app that
displays the elapsed
runtime or current pace.
However, to realize the
battery saving benefits
of ambient mode, avoid updating
the screen more than once
every 10 seconds.
Take a look at the documentation
for more details and sample
code for building great
Always-On experiences.
Remember, the user
experience you
build for Wear gets to
take advantage of the power
and flexibility of
the android platform,
along with some special
functionality just
for the wearable experience.
It's easy to get started
and possible to create
truly groundbreaking
UI for your users.
Giving them an experience
that they want when they want,
whether that's in interactive
mode or just a glance
at the ambient screen.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and I look forward
to seeing your app Always-On.
[MUSIC PLAYING]